now I didn't wear this exact outfit last
night you wouldn't notice at a dark blue
shirt on last night
you got a stay night I was brushing my
teeth this morning huh just falls on him
like everything [ __ ] I waited get water
wipe it off I'm doing an interview with
Dominick Cruz food-truck diary yeah and
he were talking us oh dude you have [ __ ]
all of you like [ __ ] oh
oh it's toothpaste sure it is oh my god
I'm like Lincoln Iza toothpaste is this
how is Dominick Cruz he's great man just
what what were you guys talking about is
he making a comment fishing Oh is he
coming is he making a comeback though
what do you mean yeah I mean he's an
analyst but he's gonna fight you he's
gonna fight yeah he's it but he had he
pulled I think he had said shoulder
surgeries he almost need me surgery with
less on his shoulder yeah Wow
his body has talked trouble with that
it's like he fights once at something
well I mean he set up 20-year career so
it's not like well your career but he
hasn't fought a lot and he hasn't fought
a lot he passed no I don't know six
years me and him talk about so he
probably had 30 fights sorry yeah
remember he's a world champion w sign
member will chairman UFC anything got
hurt yeah so he said this huge career
well then he got he got but that when
the UFC got really big yeah that's when
his injuries can be I remember oh yeah
defending I mean the best of all time
well by the way cuz oh so when you say
oh he yeah the long way up
well he had a layoff yeah I know but
hold on be before a 20-3 fight that's a
lot that's a career well I'm not
watching him if he had a hold him
because we were like we were watching
Dustin you gotta watch this guy because
he's got such an unorthodox way of
fighting he was one of the first guys
may be the first guy to really fight in
a way where you were like you hadn't
seen it really well yeah he talks about
that like people made fun of his
movement like everyone mimics it yes
he's like it correct yes you said to me
once that he's got a you and chill we're
listening them talking he's like I got
the highest IQ of any fighters I've ever
right by four he's just the best Sam
he'd be and he'd also probably be a hell
of a coach I would imagine no he is a
coach oh yes I didn't know that less oh
wow who's he why I mean that that's how
I mean he was given Chael pointers when
he's fighting john jones
I'm so smart man yeah really really good
dude yeah man yeah but it's like you
know if you're new to fighting like god
Tom Cruise oh he's injured it's you
thirty fights before all those he had a
whole career yeah was a world champion
and then it's got older that was still a
world champ either in the UFC just you
know I mean you ran up against Cody car
brand you know Cody was them but but you
remember he's a USA champion correct ya
know and then has Lane injury Donald
Rogers Tom Cruise's is one of the grill
Samer yeah one of the Great's we lost
your eye oh wow
long time ago 207 Wow but then he beat
Uriah yep defended yep and then you know
you won the bantamweight championship of
the world by being TJ Dillashaw and then
Mariah and they lost to Cody Garr Brandt
but he talked about he fought three
times that year and how just took its
toll on ya yeah I think his back was
hurt I think he's gone he said he what
he said dude that that Cody garment
fight if it was any other fight I want
to talk it out so injured light and just
beat up cuz I fought so many times that
year three was too much you know fifteen
rounds too much in a year yeah and he
was saying he said his feet were so
[ __ ] up you had to get Botox
injections so he couldn't feel the
bottom oh come on and so he fought with
that he's like you know I I lost but
he's like I'm not making excuses don't
fight yeah yeah but Cody looked
fantastic in that fight that was the
last night it's three years ago men God
that bothers me that bums me out I
didn't know he was that [ __ ] up think
about that well one of the things about
like when people say my favorite is like
well he could have fought in you have
seen well hold on for a sec or he could
have played in the pros awesome
the the even if you are able to throw
and do all that how do you play with
injuries how do you play when you can't
feel the bottom of your feet yeah but
but no one who's been in the game or
there's any experience of that because
it's not just physical skill it's about
a thousand other things how you might
manage yourself do it no one's gonna say
that on guys who have walked the walk
some people like you like it not a rock
not around incredible guys here we go
excuse me yeah yeah
it's like Mark Sanchez I was [ __ ]
around he's showing me how to throw a
football and I'm like look here's where
and he goes it's not a bad it's not a
bad release I go I'm an athlete dude I'm
an athlete and he goes take it easy man
yeah my sense is right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]